the Joe Rogan experience where do you
think selfishness came from automatic
consciousness so that's this ability to
put yourself into an experience which as
I said earlier is responsible for our
greatest achievements as a species but
also is what will potentially do us in
it allows us to not only envision a
world in which you know we can be self
less self you know not selfish but help
others but also how to exclude others
and it I think it's a natural basic
animal instinct to stay alive obviously
you know with Richard Dawkins said the
theory of The Selfish Gene animals are
incredibly selfish and you know their
struggle for existence so that kind of
automatic selfishness is there but what
the auto noetic mind allows us to do is
to be intentionally willfully selfish to
allow us to choose to do these things
for our own personal good for example I
think that the the auto noetic human
human mind is the only entity in the
history of life that's been ever to put
the organism and we're talking about the
conscious mind being a small part of the
what's going on in the cortex to put all
of the rest of the brain and all of the
body at risk for the simple sake of a
thrill mountain climbing you know
swimming and shark-infested waters or
taking drugs at dangerous levels no
other organism can commit suicide in the
sense of intentionally planning to put
an end to an entity that it knows has
the possible end so our conscious minds
are special in good ways and bad ways
yeah the conscious mind that seeks
thrills what do you think is the root of
that like I've always wondered like why
certain people are drawn to doing like
flips on mo
cycles or certain people are drawn to
climbing mountains with no ropes like
what do you think that is you know I'm
just guessing I don't really know but I
think that we each have these kind of
physiological states that that we try to
maintain you know some kind our
homeostatic levels are are different and
some people need a little more
adrenaline or a little more you know I
hate to use adrenaline in the kind of
cheap way of you know just saying it's
just more of a rush or kind of potty
activity because all that also affects
the brain and so consciously you strive
you may go looking for those kinds of
things to get the rush and it's you know
it's a it's sort of on the spectrum of
addiction in a sense where you need that
that physiological change that the drug
induces but you know we also have
addictions in our lives that our habits
and things that that we develop and
pursue they're not necessarily good for
us but that we kind of feel compelled to
do do you know Alex Honnold is yeah yeah
I've had him on podcast a couple of
times and every time I talk to him my
hands start getting sweaty for folks who
don't know who we're talking about he's
the probably the most famous free solo
climber in the world and he climbs these
seemingly impossible mountains with no
ropes and there's video of him doing it
like this drone footage of him climbing
these Peaks and my hands just pouring
but when I talk to him what's really
interesting is he's a calm rational
intelligent man who's very thoughtful
and he's he's a very kind guy he doesn't
seem like some you know I think of when
I think of someone who likes to do flips
off with a motorcycle or do radical I
think of some crazy
while thrill-seeker some some dude who
just needs to constantly or a woman who
needs to be constantly freaked out he's
not that guy and when he describes it
what's really interesting is he goes
it's very mellow he's like if there's
any if there's really a thrill I've done
something horribly wrong like the real
thrills are so scary because that means
you're about to die
so he's instead of getting the thrill
he's getting that piece yeah
but he's getting a piece from putting
himself extreme okay and there's also
the thing of other people praising you
for your risk-taking which is an odd
thing about humans and they've shown
through natural weather there's a
natural selection aspect of it with
females and mates that females are
attracted to men that do those crazy
things and take crazy risks for some
strange reason whether it's some sort of
a remnant of our ancient past like that
thrill-seeking a man has got not gonna
be he's not gonna shy away from combat
he will protect our children or
something like that right yeah I mean
there's a lot of evolutionary psychology
you know you know that a lot of that is
speculative of the horse but it's the
thrill-seeker is that's one it's one of
the weirder things when everything's
great and you have plenty of food and
you live in cities and like okay look
I'm not getting enough juice here yeah
I'm gonna have to learn how to hand
glide or something you know and yeah
some people may do it for attention yes
yeah the things people do for attention
[Applause]